this all-black feathered king penguin
could be one in a zillion the video was
recorded on the sub-antarctic island of
South Georgia by National Geographic
Traveler magazine contributing editor
Andrew Evans on his bus to Antarctica
expedition while many king penguins and
other penguins can have feather coloring
mutations usually the variations are
partial dr. Alan Baker an ornithologist
and head of the Department of Natural
History at the Royal Ontario Museum
called the discovery of the all black
king penguin astonishing he jokingly
said it's a one in a zillion kind of
mutation and scientifically calls it
very rare he explains that typically
melanistic birds will have white spots
where melanin pigmentation has failed to
color the feathers but it's extremely
rare for there to be melanin deposits
over the entire breast of a bird
photographer Evans says he almost didn't
get the sighting recorded as he got his
camera positioned the penguin started
walking away
[Music]
you